I'm Gary Clifford, I'm the interim chair of biomedical informatics at
Emory School of Medicine.
I think it's a lot of things to a lot of different people.
My own thinking is that it's where biomedical engineering meets information theory.
It's all about how do we push information around and it can be anything from
genetics through to mHealth.
I mean, you can see where we're going.
We're going to the cloud infrastructures, distributed computing,
the volume of digital data and the velocity of
digital data is just increasing exponentially and
anybody not working in the digital domain is stuck firmly in the 1970s, 1980s.
So we're either going to go backwards or we're going to go forwards.
And I think we have to go forwards, don't we?
That's the place we need to be investing.
What excites me about it
is people are generating these data and they're generating
them on an enormous scale in a very natural way.
It's a natural instrument that we interact with and it
has all the qualities that we need in a device for capturing data.
It has this suite of senses,
it has direct connections to the Internet,
it identifies the individual very specifically,
which is one of our biggest problems in medicine,
is knowing whose data belongs to who.
And it has enormous computational power on it.
I remember when we first started looking at
using phones in medicine and thinking about its potential.
You could see where it was going and you could be frustrated by the current systems,
the very early smartphones,
but you could see where the computational power is going.
Now the phone in my pocket is about
five or six times as powerful as the PC that I wrote my PhD thesis on.
So, I'm eternally excited
about the idea of this distributed computing power that we have in
our pockets and the ability for it to push data into the cloud for us
to continually track the behaviors and the healthcare,
the health of an individual.
Unlike a medical device
that you put on an individual,
a phone isn't FDA approved for medicine.
So it's difficult to use it in any validated sense.
And the reason for that is very important.
The reason is that it's a heterogeneous collection of different platforms,
it's not one device.
When you have a medical device and you put it through FDA approval,
they certify that this particular device,
running this piece of embedded software will produce the following results,
and therefore it's safe under
these conditions and it should be used for the following types of medicine.
Now, we're talking about using
these enormous heterogeneous hardware platforms
running constantly evolving software and operating systems.
The idea that you could ever come up with
a close predictable software system that the FDA would approve is a long, long way off.
So what you have is this idea that either you have to tailor it to an individual,
or you have to aggregate across large populations.
At least that's where we are at the moment with mHealth.
So, I suppose the goal at the end of the rainbow that we're chasing is
how do you provide quality healthcare information from this type of platform?
I think there's two really good examples at the moment.
There's two areas where I feel mHealth has great potential.
One is in low to middle income countries where it's sort of a tabula rasa.
We have no digital health care system or very little and
it's often a highly distributed non-centralized health care system.
So having the ability to mediate data
personally is going to be an enormous leap frog effect in health care, potentially.
So, we have a project down in Guatemala at the moment.
I just came back yesterday,
in fact we're wrapping up an RCT down there, Randomized Control Trial,
looking at the potential to use a smartphone by illiterate lay midwives.
So these are essentially women who
move from village to village looking for, by word of mouth,
for pregnant mothers and offering them help in the move through pregnancy to childbirth.
We've taken a group of 50 midwives working with an NGO.
Of course you have to work with a local partner who
already delivers a standard of health care,
and we've provided training for a smartphone
with a low cost $17 ultrasound device that plugs into the smartphone,
and a blood pressure cuff.
They screen the women monthly and they're looking for preeclampsia, high blood pressure.
They're looking for abnormalities in
the heart rate variability that are indicative of interuterine growth restriction.
This is actually a machine learning algorithm that we developed to identify our UGR,
interuterine growth restriction and also to refer
the patient on in the event that any emergencies occur.
The app is built as a series of culturally appropriate pictograms.
So we work with an anthropologist who just turns out to be my wife,
who has helped us design
the culturally appropriate interface for the largely Kaqchikel speaking,
this is an indigenous Mayan language,
Kaqchikel speaking group of midwives and all of the support system,
all the help files are spoken in Kaqchikel and all the data is recorded in Kaqchikel.
There's no written language actually for this,
which makes IAB approval for it quite difficult,
but it's a fun system to build because you're basically
building a decision support system for an illiterate group.
The intervention comparison, so the other arm of the intervention
is simply the same pictograms printed on
a piece of card and then laminated so that it's waterproof,
and then we train another group of midwives to use,or
traditional birth attendants to use
that laminated cardboard as a decision support system.
So it directly testing is a technology based on a smartphone that
connects a decision support system straight through to a health care system.
More efficacious than a dumb phone or feature phone with the number
programmed into it and a cardboard with the same decision support mechanism in there.
I can't tell you the results of that,
because we're only just wrapping up the RCT at the moment,
but the informal numbers show that there's been a significant impact on the population.
The question of whether you can take people
with very little exposure to a smartphone system,
although they do use quite complex phones themselves,
and use that in a healthcare setting,
there are strong indications that that's entirely possible and in fairly large numbers.
So that's a pretty exciting one.
We have an enormous potential there.
We're connecting the phone directly through to an electronic medical record system,
which is an open source system.
The entire thing is built on open source technology
and the price point is extremely low for the entire system.
So that's got me really excited.
You know the idea that we can transform health care by providing these enablers,
but there's another layer to it that's really exciting I think.
When you take a smartphone system.
You don't just have to give information to a user,
you're capturing information from them at the same time.
So, these lay midwives have lots of
local cultural knowledge about
how receptive the mothers are going to be to certain treatments,
and even down to the points of different colors mean different things in medicine,
and there are hot colors and cold colors,
and some illnesses or medical conditions are hot and some are cold.
And if you use the wrong color,
then it no longer becomes trusted.
So, having the right cultural approach to something is very important,
and we can capture this information back from the midwives at the same time because they
can create logs of what does and doesn't work as they're moving through this process.
So it's a continual system that we built with the midwives.
We learnt from them,
we adapted to their own cultural practices,
and they became an inclusive part of the construction of this.
And so, I think that's where we're going with mHealth.
It's not this didactic patriarchal western medicine where we just say,
here's the drug, here's the app.
Now you give me your information back and I will give you the cure.
I think it's going to become an organic system where we're feeding information back,
and we are learning from the user.
It's also got the potential to create
a distributed system that allows users to pass information between each other.
So now you could have different midwives having social conversations through
the phone and exchanging
information about- I'm not saying we're doing this at the moment,
but this is the next step I think.
They can interface with each other,
exchange information from a support network,
and we can capture this information at the same time and
work out what's working, what's not working,
and even ask each other to diagnose problems when we don't have
the bandwidth for the centralized doctor
or nurse to provide the clinical information they need.
So I think there's an evolution to mHealth that is coming that is
somewhere between distributed computing and crowd sourcing that is going to
allow us to harness
the local knowledge of individuals and the wisdom of the crowd if you like.
Sure, this is just as exciting to me actually,
and it's a home grown project in that it's a
U.S. based project in Atlanta primarily,
but we're expanding it to the southeast.
We last year we got funding from the NSF to
realize a project that we've been hatching for a couple of years now.
About two years ago,
Dr. Herman Taylor is the head of the cardiovascular research institute at
Morehouse School of Medicine came to me and said that he wanted to expand and build
an e-cohort of
African American pre CBD cardiovascular disease subjects.
And he had run previous to this the Jackson heart study which is
the largest cardiovascular study of African American subjects anywhere in the world.
And this had been ongoing for 20 or so years,
looking at the evolution of cardiovascular disease.
And one of the things they had done as part of this
was to bring people from the community
in and train them in concepts around cardiovascular disease,
and they became part of the study group that was studying the population as well.
And this is as you probably know,
a difficult thing to do in disadvantaged communities in the United States.
So you know the more disadvantaged you are,
the more marginalized you are as a community,
the more likely you are to have health issues.
And in the United States as in many places,
these communities have often been unfairly experimented on.
You know we have the- that's a very modern euphemism for what's going on in the past.
So if you look at things like Tuskegee and
many other abhorrent things that have occurred in
the past where the establishment has experimented on disadvantaged populations,
you can see that there's an enormous distrust of
these populations for people like myself or anybody who
represents some figure role authority to
come in and ask people to give up their data and become part of a study.
So we we had talked about how we would do this with eHealth and mHealth in
a new population primarily looking at younger African Americans in Atlanta.
And we talked about how we could build an app ecosystem,
and an open source infrastructure that would not only
be available to the communities that we are hoping to monitor,
but we would actively involve them in learning how to
program and how to become part of the project to
empower them to be able to produce code for
themselves which would increase their economic situation.
They would also learn about health care at the same time,
so they would improve their understanding of their own bodies and their own healthcare,
and they would also be empowered to be
a part of an open source community and
an open source project and give back to their own communities.
So the idea was to bring these communities in and make them part of this project.
And we're just at the point now where we realize we've got the funding for this,
and we're working with the communities.
We've been to multiple community coalitions
to look at how we would sensitively recruit people into this.
And this weekend actually,
we're running an idea on why we're bringing in hundreds of
local potential participants in this to work with us on ideating around the app,
what they want it to look like.
We're actually collecting what they want the app to do.
We're collecting information on what geographic location,
activity, sleep movements, what restaurants they visit,
what pollution they're being exposed to.
There's no end of what you can pull from somebody's cell phone.
But the question is, will somebody give us this information?
And there's a cyber security issue around this.
How does somebody even trust you when you know pretty much.
The question isn't will I get hacked?
It is what will I do when I get hacked?
That's the question nowadays around security.
So, how do you get somebody to trust them to allow you to use this kind of system.
So, we're building this with the communities,
we're going to train them how to,
and we already are training them how to code on
this platform and become part of it to understand the language that we're coding in,
and what information we're actually asking people to give
us in order to do this kind of longitudinal study in cardiovascular disease.
So, this is something that's really exciting to me,
that it's a new way of doing research.
I think it takes participatory research right to its limit.
We actually want people to take the platform,
take ownership of it,
build companies out of it,
and change their health and economic status as a result of it.
That's pretty ambitious, but I think we have a great team around it,
and I'm excited to see where we can take it.